in our series a more perfect union we
aim to show that what unites us as
Americans is far greater than what
divides us Arizona teachers went on
strike just over a year ago to fight for
increased funding for their schools and
better pay Carter Evans visited a second
grade class in Phoenix where one
teachers message resonated with a
complete stranger thousands of miles
away and they then decided to help what
genre is the golden flower the school
year is coming to a close at whispering
wind Academy in Phoenix but for the very
first time Elizabeth millage is not
digging into her own pocket to purchase
supplies for her second-grade class to
have dry erase markers like unbelievable
and even to have this much paper at the
end of the year it's like so excited
Arizona teachers have some of the lowest
salaries in the country just one of the
reasons they went on strike last year
mrs. millage posted her frustrations on
Facebook
sharing her salary of just over $35,000
a year a grand of which she spends on
her classroom I think it just kind of
snapped for me like I make so little
money and yet have to outfit my entire
room there's no supply closet you can go
get scotch tape no there's no paper
clips no I mean how are you supposed to
do your job without these things so I'm
at Walmart buying my own garbage can for
my classroom and I'm laughing as I'm
pushing the cart because I'm like only a
teacher what have a giant garbage can
for their classroom that they're buying
out of their own pocket her post went
viral and in New York City it caught the
eye of Ben Adam who works in real estate
he sent mrs. millage a message it just
said has anybody offered to buy your
class supplies and I thought well that's
an odd message and so I responded no and
then he reached out to me again and said
I would like to buy any supplies you
might need for the beginning of the
school year there's got to be a catch
there wasn't I felt that for very little
I can do a lot of good and I can feel
good about myself
the daily struggles have so many
educators struck a nerve with Ben of
course that
feeling is contagious and a few months
later I wanted to have the same feeling
against an acid if he needed more
supplies for the following semester and
that's what started the ball rolling
Amazon boxes started arriving in my
classroom and I'm like oh my goodness
this is crazy who is this guy
I know he's like the best then six weeks
ago Ben went one step further
he built a classroom giving website
where teachers post supplies they need
and donors from anywhere in the country
can help pay for them this is like a
wedding registry meets Secret Santa and
there is no commitment in just the past
two weeks the website is blown up 275
teachers from 31 states have requested
supplies so far 37 have had their
wishlist filled pictures and notes from
grateful teachers and kids are already
pouring in give him a box and it's like
Christmas from paints and crayons to
novels
mrs. Millett told her students they were
all gifts from their New York friend
what did you think when you found out
this guy from New York was giving you
all this stuff I think I know those rich
no no absolutely not I am NOT a wealthy
man I own a small business but I also
work he's very generous and kind and
that I would do anything to meet him and
say thank you I just want to give him a
hug I don't know if he's a hugger but I
just want to hug it no doubt it would be
a bear sized hug but for now mrs.
millage and the kids will go with a
heartfelt thank you to the guy who's in
a class of his own for CBS this morning
Carter Evans Phoenix Arizona mines me
very much a donor to ya where you can
donate to a school specifically just
exactly what he's doing too but this is
great it's wonderful proof you can help
a teacher any way anywhere and teachers
need help everywhere else you spend a
lot out of their own pockets